більше про підготовку до нового
навчального року дізнаємося від Сергія
шкарлета міністра освіти і науки України
він зараз доєднується до нашого ефіру п
Сергія вас вітаю Слава Україні
Героям слава Доброго дня пане Сергію ви
озвучували інформацію що приблизно 30%
закладів готові доочного навчання восени
а чи не замало це власне зважаючи на те
що 1 вересня вже Буквально за місяць і
власне що мають робити самі навчальні
заклади та місцева Влада щоб встигнути
все-таки підготуватися краще
Дуже дякую за запитання перш за все і
дуже дякую за увагу до освітян адже це
наше майбутнє їм саме освіта формує
свідому українця який здатний побудувати
зовсім іншу державу після навали цієї
російської агресії
ви знаєте в принципі на початку липня в
нас було набагато менше відсотків
готовності і десь в районі 17-18 на 1
серпня ми можемо констатувати що 30%
об'єктів вже готові до початку офлайн
адже разом з ДСНС проведено майже 30
тисяч перевірок
звісно ніхто не очікував цієї підсудної
атаки підступної агресії підступної
війни і коріння підготовки закладів
освіти щодо надзвичайних ситуацій щодо
укриттів бомбосховищ вони далеко-далеко
посідають ще до початку війни і
п'ятирічної десятирічний термін Тому вже
були
Які формували засади безпеки формування
закладів освіти На жаль маємо це
спадкоємність в цій проблемі але на
сьогодні держава разом з місцевими
органами разом з засновниками разом з
колегами змін розвитку громад та
території Міністерства внутрішніх справ
до сндс Ми намагаємося якнайбільше
забезпечити шкіл саме укриттями для того
щоб освітній процес розпочинався в
максимальному режимі офлайн але Хочу
наголосити безпека на першому місці
батьки будуть обирати якщо батько або
мати вважає що дитина є небезпека для
відвідання Шкоди в цьому контексті діти
можуть навчатися за програмою онлайн або
сімейною або індивідуальним навчанням
або екстернотом Тому ці умови
передбаченілись
30%, звичайно звісно замало Але
сподіваюсь що на кінець
серпня ми будемо мати більше
оптимістичну оці
нку тобто Наскільки я розумію от власне
наявність надійних укриттів це власне і
є головний аргумент для того щоб школи
почали працювати офлайн звичайно безпека
безпека і ще раз безпека для заради цієї
безпеки є не тільки інструментарій
наявності укриттів є ще організації
форми організації освітнього процесу
можливо це змінність можливо це
формування змішаного навчання в частині
частина дисциплін онлайн частина офлайн
для того щоб максимально зменшити
кількість одночасно перебування всіх
учасників освітнього процесу На
території школи І загальний слоган
Сьогодні який є це школа території
безпеки і саме вчитель навчений вчитель
Ми сьогодні проводимо майже 7 тисяч
занять вже провели ДСНС разом з
міністерством освіти щодо навчання
педагогів щодо навчання шляхів навчання
евакуації навчання погодження в тому
числі і спротивної діяльності тобто
безпековий сьогодні характер побудови
наших стосунків всередині освітнього
процесу і забезпечення впевненості
батьків в тому що школа території
безпеки це є основа підготовки додому
навчання
а Чи можемо ми зараз вже говорити про
кількість учнів власне яка прогнозована
кількість наповненість класів чи можливо
взагалі пропустити що якийсь відсоток
дітей може залишитися зараз за кордоном
А на сьогодні ви знаєте об'єктивно Дякую
за запитання дуже слушне Враховуючи те
що в нас орієнтовно було взагалі 4 млн
200 учасників освітнього процесу саме
учнів в заклади загальної середньої
освіти за кордоном сьогодні перебуває
641 000 по нашому рахунку і
але є певна тенденція адже на початку
наприклад навіть травня було 671 000 на
сьогодні 641 тобто 30 тисяч дітей вже
повернулися до навчання так багато
внутрішньо переміщеннях осіб це питання
вирішується сьогодні тим що будь-яку
школу будь-який батько будь-яка дитина
буде влаштована і не залишить освітнього
процесу жодна дитина не залишиться
позаосвітнім процесом на сьогодні
регулярні щотижневі наради з керівниками
департаментів обласних департаментів
освіти з мерами міста засновниками
проводяться і
висловлюється алгоритми Міністерство
запропонувало ціну низько алгоритмів як
діяти в тих чи інших умовах для того щоб
жодна дитина не залишилась позаосвітніми
Сергію війна все-таки триває І власне Не
всі школи не у всіх містах школи зможуть
працювати
офлайн от буквально пару днів тому
спілкувався в ефірі з мером Харкова і
громтерковом і він сказав що ну Харків
навряд чи
запустить школи
офлайн А ми за запитання і за приклад Я
особисто був в Харкові адже є в нас
території де ведуться активні бойові дії
ні про які у освіту онлайн офлайн
Вибачте в на території громад в яких
ведуться активні бойові дії не ведеться
взагалі звісно звісно там
освітній процес буде відбуватися знову ж
таки виключно в умовах безпеки і рішення
буде прийматися на місцях керівниками
військових адміністрацій відповідно до
безпекової ситуації і те що не всі школи
відкриються жахливо вам статистику
наведу адже на сьогодні 226 закладів
освіти повністю зруйновано і
1981 пошкоджено приклад наведу дані по
ефіру який я виходив вчора було 225 і
1975 6 закладів освіти за добу але в
цілому в середньому ми жодної доби не
обходимося без Ну воно або пошкодженого
закладу освіти російськими снарядами
бомбами ракетним
пане Сергію пройшов мультипредметний
тест які власне висновки можете зробити
після того як відбулося це тестування і
які бали набрали Наші учні Чи задовільні
ви знаєте якщо врахувати що 224
приблизно 224 тисячі випускників 11-х
класів на сьогодні мали
проходити або вступати до закладів вищої
освіти фахової перевищує освіти в
Україні то на сьогодні ми маємо
оптимістичну картину адже на основну
сесію було зареєстровано майже 207 тисяч
на додаткову 25 000 дітей і в нас ще
буде спеціальна сесія третя для того щоб
дати можливість кожному з випускників
визначитись і навчатись саме в Україні
причому 32 країни світу долучилися до
складанням цього національного руху
конкретного тиску і в нас Майже 25 000
дітей майже 30 тисяч дітей зареєстровано
за кордоном для того щоб складати
мультиплектний тест і навчатися в
закладах дослідів закладах України хочу
сказати що в цілому є позитивний
схвальне схвальна оцінка і абітурієнтами
і батьками саме процедури і формату
складання всього національного мультику
адже він дозволяє конкурсу оцінити
знання за один раз випускники мають
можливість самостійно обрати місце де
вони будуть тестуватись і це онлайн
одразу отримують результати свого
тестування Це набагато простіше так же
враховуючи ту безпеку ситуації яка
сьогодні є в Україні це є єдиною
сьогодні можливістю швидко онлайн і
непрозоро вступити до закладів вищої
освіти
А скажіть будь ласка в середньому по
балах можу сказати що бали-бали середні
середня оцінка балів складання
національного мультиплекторного тесту
взагалі-то досить пристойно виглядає є
дуже значна кількість учасників які
сьогодні отримують найвищі бали і це нас
тішить
А скажіть будь ласка що враховувати от
Досвід цього року якщо от власне Досвід
цього мультипредметного тесту все-таки
буде визнаний вдалим чи можливо що
міносвіти зробить його постійним
замінивши тим самим мабуть більш складне
для дітей ЗНО
А ви знаєте
мені здається ранувато говорити про це
адже ЗНО і нмт
повністю співставити не можна Я хочу
нагадати що національний мультиплідний
тест використовується виключно на прийом
22-23 навчального року і як альтернатива
ЗНО в умовах
воєнного стану а вже після
висновки подивимось якість вступників це
вже заклади вищої освіти будуть
оцінювати перший семестр другий і будемо
дивитись на наступний рік яким чином ми
будемо далі крокувати по цьому формату
по формату вступу але компанія на
наступний
пане Сергію вам дуже вдячний що ви
знайшли можливість доєднатися до нашого
ефіру і відповіли на наше запитання тому
що вони дуже важливі зараз я думаю
абсолютно для всіх українців це був
Сергій До побачення Це був Сергій
шкарлет Міністр освіти і науки України